well it's incorrect and you know it's
very interesting because I tried to
watch as much as I could I wasn't able
to watch too much because I've been a
little bit busy but I think having a
fake hearing like that and having it in
the middle of this very important summit
is really a terrible thing they could
have made it two days later or next week
and it would have been even better they
would have had more time but having it
during this very important summit is
sort of incredible and he lied a lot but
it was very interesting because he
didn't lie about one thing he said no
collusion with the Russian hoax and I
said I wonder why he didn't just lie
about that - like you did about
everything else I mean he lied about so
many different things and I was actually
impressed that he didn't say well I
think there was collusion for this
reason or that he didn't say that he
said no collusion and I was getting a
little impressed by that frankly could
have he could have gone all out he only
went about 95 percent instead of a
hundred percent but the fact is there is
no collision and I call it the witch
hunt this should never happen to another
president this is so bad for our country
so bad you look at this whole hoax it's
a I call it the Russian witch hunt I now
add the word hoax it's a very very bad
thing for our country but I was
impressed with the fact that he went you
know because the most important question
up there was the one on collusion and he
said he saw no collusion so we'll see
what happens but it was a pretty
shameful I think